spectacle ce mini laboratoire portable
développé par une entreprise d'ottawa
servira dorénavant à dépister si une
personne est d'atteindre de la coved 19
alors voici le crime ça peut être prêt
de livres et la faire sans que ça
fonctionne c'est que le les tampons
comme ça on prend six semaines soit du
nez ou de la gorge et ensuite on leur en
temps le système qui est ici alors toute
la chimie toute la technologie est ici
dans le boue ici fait qu'il ait pas
d'autres séparations et notre
préparation alors en direct à partir si
comme ça dans le système et ensuite on
ne met dans la machine et si tout s'est
fini ans dans trente minutes on a nos
résultats de caubel
le cube était déjà utilisé pour dépister
la présence de bactéries comme celle
responsable de la maladie du légionnaire
l'entreprise l'a adapté à la kobe 19 et
a reçu le feu vert de santé canada
l'appareil et les tests seront d'abord
distribués sur le marché canadien
dès le début du mois de mai on en a
commandé pour être capable d'en faire
deux cent mille donc qu'on pense qu'avec
ça ou être capable de fait les tests
qu'on a besoin dans les prochaines
semaines il s'agit d'un test adn très
simple particulièrement utile à
l'extérieur des grands hôpitaux
notamment dans les régions éloignées
comme les milieux ruraux de l'ontario
nous avons des problèmes au niveau de
transport avec le test donc j'espère
qu'on va voir dans le liste prioritaire
par contre cet homme c'est un problème à
travers dans thériault mais ce genre
d'appareil a des limites
par contre je vous dirais matin
laboratoire par exemple comme le nom
tout des laboratoires par exemple dans
les hôpitaux de montréal c'est des
outils qui sont peut-être moins
intéressant parce que chez nous on doit
faire plusieurs centaines parfois de
tests par jour chaque mini laboratoire
ne peut faire qu'un seul test à la fois
ici vincent maisonneuve race au canada